Oh
[Music]
today making Swedish pancakes let's fly
American pancakes
what is this disgusting sweet pancakes
was one of the first things I learned to
make in terms of cooking it's very
simple anyone can make it and all the
sudden you were realized these are the
best pancakes you could make all other
pancakes fairly in comparison it's not
right Marcia she says yes with there's
so much confident I'm how much you know
because I'm so tall look at this so all
right eggs flour my assistants we can
use protein powder as flour Oh muscle
gain this illegal butter yeah salt milk
and then you put the jam my templates
the tallow and pancakes this is probably
one of the hardest things for me to
accept with our marriage that might say
it wants to put into telling you put can
you put can you should try one stop
shaking pepper the best thing about this
recipe my dad taught me this recipe
because my pancakes every year Sunday
and then his mom would cook pancakes
rather than every week as well so it's a
Swedish tradition and switch paintings
often get mixed up with the cracks
yeah my Sicily no no we're not making
friends well people think sweets bangers
are crazy but they're not the recipe is
from actually my dad said the recipe is
from like a Donald Duck Magazine recipe
you guys read on a lot I know the
Swedish epic thing yeah you guys come on
with Donald OTT yes the recipe is so
easy because you can remember it in your
head so 100 milliliter is one this later
British people I hate you why are you
doing this okay I'm just gonna I'm gonna
skip the protein is to complicate
already I'm my brain is confusing okay
two deciliters of flour Bing these are
not best leader so I have to adjust it
bang
this is for two people two eggs and
remember that to to bein being bank bone
one that Gary's watching this was great
in fact you can't see him
oh you're making Swedish pancakes that's
my favorite I rob free to pancake
they're not like those French crepes and
there's crack the American lunch Thank
You Hector thank you hey they're all in
wrong order
Oh God that frickin will disappear like
this next up and get the milk I don't
usually drink milk but I don't I want to
be true to the recipe so for this a
liters of milk so two to four that's all
you gotta remember wait so this is 215
someone for ya yeah I'll do a little
incentive why are you laughing yes yes
what a bit of salt it's important not to
forget the salt I usually just do like
that okay that looks good bang now we
whisk this baby I remember my dad always
whisking like this and I was like make
sure your whisk it properly look at this
technique my dad would be proud
my grandma would put a sour milk instead
of regular milk I don't think you have
sour milk in UK but it's really good it
sounds gross but it's good I think this
is too much flour excellent
[Music]
dude this was an anime I've been
watching ever worse this would be in
slow motion oh my god
he's risking so good
impossible how does he do it so well ahh
are you impressed Marcin that looks nice
nice and even no bits of flour in there
just curl up okay
actually I should have heated up the
pants while I did this I'm sorry to be
fair
science has helped us make pants go
quicker then when I I probably put way
too much butter in it but I don't care
not only just
[Music]
and we don't have a spatula we used to
have to I wonder where they I throw away
what we don't mean I kind of want to put
on the things it would be too loud for
just a magic sign anything fan noise
yeah yeah spread out the butter
come on what's so funny I'm making
pancakes you want to make sure that it's
spread out evenly across so that it
doesn't stick to the pan
once you flip it and you want it this
golden golden fly a forever yes you like
that within the fluid give it another
extra waste okay and then you pour it
this is very important for from the
center make sure it's even
beautiful I think I put too much goddamn
but I'm a nice name do the same thing
I'm the other one perfect
now too thick now not too thick
these are not American pancakes they're
not supposed to dick but they're not
then like crepes even look at this bad
boy
oh yeah now we milled one wing Sweden
called laptop stolen oh but this is
already getting finished it's a too hard
to store yeah see that looks good you're
still showing the other one what are you
doing I just fly with it yeah that's
normal that's extra flavor as we call a
flower kick we call that experience got
a bit of flour in my mouth you want to
check underneath oh look at that Marcia
look at this get over me
see this beautiful that's actually
pretty good
I always thought it was so cool when
people flip the pancakes just a little
bit more I'm just so nervous I mean I'm
not I know what I'm doing oh I think the
pancake doesn't work out no oh I scared
him sorry
[Music]
patience is the key of the mastering of
Swedish pancake it's like watching a
flower from the beach
so if you do the recipe to 2x2 flower
and for milk that's for two people if
you want to increase the amount you do
three eggs free flour six milk and they
wore for fire forward even yeah you're
gonna be saying thank you
I don't want something okay you ready
for the first flip think we're ready by
being beautiful I like mine a little
browner you like them liner so this will
be yours this looks like a weird
a really fat America or something Mexico
code for that it's right there there
Seattle
I know where Seattle ice now thank you
looks like a little crab leg you just
like it saying hey oh oh that's a a
don't worry I can save this oh no God
what is that Oh doesn't this make you
hungry I bet chefs are watching this
like how is he doing oh I think this one
is ready for a little bit but this is my
only good pancake what are coming today
I'll eat it whoa 360 baby intentional
way my way my man that's how you know
I'm a gamer all right it's ready look a
little thicker than I want yeah what is
this one gonna look like
like the little thinner this race it's a
monster I don't even know what okay that
looks good yeah just some so many more
time some room later than others nothing
wrong with it
I remember you can only eat this for
breakfast or lunch if you just were been
there there's something wrong with you
and when I was a kid at birthday parties
that were sometimes give us pancakes for
for dinner
and I was always like that's illegal
ready boom that was good
could be more significant but yeah it's
alright
this one looks okay this is my first one
that's why this I guess I'm gonna put
chalice I'll put yours on this one I'll
put mine how about that if you want the
Thai language right you put your own a
camel it's not even don't show I mean
look at that so beautiful
Susan pretty yeah so even Oh what that's
normal that's knocked out that's normal
what it fluffs I'm falling
yeah there's balls inside chocolate
which says Swedish cooking technique
cold for let's step over pop this will
be mine because I failed man make sure
they're round oh god it looks like a guy
that picks is lying that's beautiful you
want this one oh excuse me
[Music]
bang bang bang am i singing why you'd be
so symmetric okay
notice how I open the jam not even a
problem bro spoon fish your being my mum
and you spread it across like this no
Nutella no stupid syrup no stupid baby
and then you roll that [ __ ] you
roll it oh oh that looks good yeah
beautiful
thank you mmm oh this is beautiful
[Music]
there's a little thing that says that's
pretty good
not all pancakes receipt the same just
like people being mama what yeah like
I'm doing your thing
[Music]
a little burnt but you know that's life
there we have it in all its glory
Swedish pancakes look how much better
mine look at my you helped a bit with
presentation just a tiny bit okay for
the taste test also you gotta have milk
with it important you can't drink water
okay don't care if you're lactose
intolerant buy your fake thank you again
first bye here we go oh damn laughter
thank you
that takes me back man Swedish pancakes
you should try it it's good it ain't
crepes any nein American but it's got
them good god dammit so again I missed
it
how's that
[Music]
why does milk taste so good with
pancakes so good alright that's it folks
that's the recipe post your version of
this recipe on the reddit I want to see
what you guys made as well
hope this was epic of course it was
Swedish pancakes and I see you guys
tomorrow in another video Hado hey hey
[Music]
it's time to race what was one forgotten
what creatures for spells and poop
troops awaits poop tea is coming to
Nintendo's wait and remember it has a
very big TV pre-order promotion I mean
[Music]
yeah jmes checkbook birthday girl of I
know
[Music]